Mike Pence malfunctioned at a completely
cringe-worthy town hall on CNN last
night this is absolutely beyond belief
former vice president Mike Pence had a
really bad town hall on CNN last night
in which he among other things got a
lady's name wrong and then just went
silent for five seconds uh really really
odd the the bigger question is why he's
even doing Town Halls on CNN right now
you might say well it's because he's
maybe running in 24. uh maybe right now
the predictive markets don't look very
good for Mike Pence so check out this
clip this is one of the wildest Clips
I've seen a lady named Andrea asks a
question and Penn's call Pence calls her
Barbara and then it gets really weird
and Pence appears to malfunction now I
admit I watch this about 10 times last
night I was laughing so hard to myself I
almost woke up my sleeping baby daughter
check this out now the the Andrea's last
name is Barbara Dansby so Barbara wasn't
completely pulled out of thin air but
her name isn't Barbara it's Andrea when
Andrea corrects Mike Pence he he sort of
seems to freeze and glitch it was almost
trump-like check this out and this
Freedom based on Roe also continue
Barbara thank you I represented Madison
County in Congress for many years Andrea
it's nice to see you
that that pause was not I did I did
nothing to doctor that uh very very
strange pause
this is a kafka-esque moment I I know I
know it's been months since I brought
out kafka-esque this is unbelievable
Barbara thank you that my name's Andrea
good to see you and then he says nothing
I am let's just just take it in one more
time for its full cringe-worthy glory
and this Freedom based on Roe also
continue
Barbara thank you I represented Madison
County in Congress for many years Andrea
it's nice to see you
you know when I oh dear God okay so it
was only downhill from there if you can
imagine that wasn't even the worst
moment so the first actual question that
Penn Scott it was such a softball that I
thought this was all going to be a waste
of time look look at how soft this
question is whether you love him or hate
him yeah former president Trump now
candidate Trump is a polarizing figure
who brought controversial issues to the
Forefront of American politics
how does the country move past the
polarization and find Common Ground
solutions to these important issues
facing this nation I mean it's Pence's
answer doesn't even matter that's the
prototypical softball question and of
course Pence has no idea how to bring
the country together he's part of the
Evangelical right-wing movement that has
sowed division in the country for
decades it Pence is completely uh
unqualified to answer the question but
so soft but then it actually got kind of
interesting CNN actually showed video
showed Pence video of The Gallows where
Trump supporters wanted to hang Pence on
January 6. now Pence has developed a a
sort of um demeanor during these moments
where he will sort of like pause and act
like he's thinking very deeply and it's
very you know important what to say it's
all contrived but it's still interesting
to confront him with this video check
this out um take you back to that day
take a look at the video over here
um that of course was the news hanging
outside the capitol that day and rioters
were calling for your execution uh
chanting hang Mike Pence almost two
years later is it still tough to there's
some of the video of the Hang Mike Pence
two years later is it still tough to see
that and hear that
he's thinking now
Jake it it saddens me sad
but that day it angered me
yeah I must tell you when uh
I don't know
when the Secret Service took us down to
the loading dock accompanied by my wife
my daughter Charlotte and our secret
service detail
I was determined to stay at my post I
told the Secret Service that I was not
leaving the Capitol
I didn't want to give those people the
sight of a 16-car motorcade speeding
away from the capitol that day right
but frankly when I saw those images
and when when I read a tweet that
President Trump issued
saying that I lack courage in that
moment
it angered me greatly
but to be honest with you I didn't have
time for it
yeah
um it's all just very strange and I get
the idea
that what Pence is trying to do here is
sort of like project strength and calm
and an unwavering demeanor but at the
same time it all continues to be sort of
like you realize the guy you worked for
almost got you killed right I mean that
literally almost in the sense that of
course he had Secret Service potential
protection but his followers wanted you
dead this wasn't Democrats this was your
side and then at another point the town
hall almost gets like an intervention
type vibe if I were you I would still be
livid with Donald Trump
I would be so Furious
and I know you're a measured man right
um but are you still angry
well I must tell you the president's
words and tweet that day were Reckless
they endangered my family and
and all the people at the Capitol
and I was angry
but you know my Christian faith tells me
to be quick to listen
slow to speak and slow to become angry
all right so then he just goes into
Christian stuff and says you know we
forgive and so on and so forth so the
question why was he doing this at all I
don't really know the answer the betting
Market's now on the question of who will
win the 2024 Republican nomination have
this quite frankly as just a race
between Rhonda sandis and Donald Trump
and Mike Pence is sort of like in a tied
for third position alongside Nikki Haley
and Glenn youngin so what this means for
the future of Pence I don't really know
but it was certainly interesting to hear
where his head was yesterday uh and it's
all very very strange and uh remains to
be seen whether Pence will actually run
but what very very he's just a strange
guy I think at the end of the day of the
day is what I'm realizing he also
appeared on Fox News let's take a look
at that appearance real quick one of our
sponsors is monk pack making amazing
granola bars and the nut and Seed bars
that are chewy Sweet and delicious but I
especially love them because each bar
has has only one gram of sugar two to
three net carbs and about 150 calories
perfect if you do keto or low carb or
like me you're just trying to stay
conscious about sugar intake you get the
satisfying crunchy salty sweet
experience you were looking for without
the sugar monk pack comes in flavors
like sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea
salt they launch two new flavors which
are great peanut butter cocoa chip and
dark chocolate cocoa I keep monk pack
granola bars and nut and Seed bars in
the pantry at all times they're great on
the go for a quick snack while you're
working if you don't love them as much
as I and our team do monk pack will
refund all of your money or exchange the
product whichever you prefer go to
monkpak.com and you'll get 20 off your
first order with the code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below